[Music]
and money rage news submitted by at
local that's not a man goes on a rampage
in 7-eleven after his credit card is
declined 475 fans huh whoa wait
his carve-out declined after 75 cents
should be faster a bit a man keep didn't
have enough to cover sin Phi sin but I
mean credit cards decline yeah over the
limit if you go over the limit or
something like what if you need class
for a lot of reasons you let a lot of
the reasons usually doesn't tell you the
reason we have to call it in
I do like chase though when your [ __ ]
declines well it's like if they think
it's brought you get an email like
immediately like a half a second they
just go right to the email and you go
that's me [ __ ]
and then you're good it takes you two if
you want connexes don't give me a text
and I'm like oh it's me and then I'm
like okay cool not try to blah blah blah
blah Blau chase thank you very much
customer service is always amazing
please give me money yeah MX gloves a
senior amen I'm with both me too ice
crystals I hate be fixed you know that
nowadays they don't and they just email
me and then they want me to call on this
number and then what I call in then they
go away what do you want on my mother
[ __ ] you're the one who told me to call
you you should know exactly why I'm
calling you and they always decline my
card for no reason is this you it's very
suspicious activity when you pump gas
[ __ ] I was pumping gas
second gas station I always pop it in
yeah what's that what's so suspicious
about that I will close our account
Bank of America you better start giving
him money what if he in traffic I tell
you the time sorry but I think I was
moving a lot of money around right and
then in one of them I think I had an
additional grand that was accidentally
deposited to my account lucky I didn't a
16 minutes ago but it was nice
where did these come from I want to just
spend the [ __ ] out of it no you can they
track it because they see there's a
paper trail so no I always thought that
so they still take it out Albin like
what the hell you didn't tell me where
my money goes no that's shady I thought
that I
what I just did like I know what the
hell I would do the whole angry one we
would be like where do you think that
money came from sir you know what do you
not believe in the love of Jesus Christ
oh yeah oh wow that is amazing why I was
gonna save your soul but clearly you're
gonna go to hell and your child too
amen you never heard of Marilyn she does
magic then hit him up for your thousand
six thousand bucks that's crazy I never
get those fortunate events I don't even
I've only found my twenty books on the
floor that was like the most asked Oh
like the luckiest I've ever seen don't
ask from less some more just keep it
it's awesome
no this man police are still looking as
far as I know the last time I heard this
man went on the craziest rampage after
his card was declined when he was trying
to buy some eminence Eminem stole that
spell jivey crazy though all minute
yo what Eminem were 75 cents I know I
was thinking the same thing
like really goodness 75 cent
insufficient funds so it's like a balla
seven to five it's like maybe had a
dollar left but a 75 regular menem's are
chocolate M&Ms almond nobody [ __ ]
there's an almond M&M is a care mom and
into oh there's a peanut butter wanted
huh you know what clearly I don't know
my Candy's very long there's all this
new [ __ ] that came out yeah dude I'm
stuck back in the day man I'm lying I
hate Eminem I did it for the video
[Laughter]
you hate Eminem video I don't want to
have a crunch I couldn't hold it I can't
I can't lie to you guys but I can't do
it why don't you like it
it's [ __ ] gross oh that's nasty dude
[ __ ] math yes chocolate playing again
I the P no one's okay but still dude
they give you like the bottom barrel
chocolate we're all kind of like you
know Manish it's grandma's candy I love
candy how do you feel about her she this
is crazy I feel like if a grandma was
like having this conversation right
people what would you prefer
but appease or Werther's Originals Oh
water tap
I love saltwater taffy oh god they like
that [ __ ] candy that's in that wax
paper a saltwater candy if you go to Old
Town Sacramento there's a I've been
there right I got you a whole bag of my
mother came back it was gone so quick
they straight-up make their salt when I
was happy that I had this just I was a
little kid awesome it is is it like
savory and sweet because I never had
move it's sweet but there's a little
hint of salinity in there yeah yeah let
him explain the food its chewy its weak
its creamy it's like a taffy Asia
saltwater taffy SH this is actually put
salt in there and water where's the
conversationally I don't know guys video
of him going crazy so it takes place in
Santa Ana by the way oh [ __ ] neighbor
it's got a 7-eleven it is 11 I'm not
like this an earlier moment I know what
the uniforms look like who's the person
that's gonna go crazy guess not regime
he is not in this frame ball which one
picaros [ __ ] show up soon alright
here we go
there's no sound is this crazy man
so it seems like they're like he's
already like arguing about something
which they don't report all the reports
say that he was only upset over the card
decline how can you get mad at the
person though Oh course your finger that
mean biz
well I pull this finger Megamart oh my
god oh you miss it
Oh what other guy nothing to do with it
yeah you want booze homie with him -
well I can't a friend I just all my
walked out I think that's just a guy
that's just a go back to the first hit
and I know where he has to play there
how do people get so angry on a 7-eleven
so keep talking walking back and forth
all right here comes the hit put my
finger you don't want to pull my finger
well I'm trying to pull my finger [ __ ]
you then [ __ ] don't even hit him he
just placed his head on his head he went
like hell yes
yeah and it's nothing like he was with
that guy how do people get a so [ __ ]
angry over nothing the [ __ ] I was
like oh I feel like he's having a really
really really bad day me somebody has
like terrible anger management he's like
why don't you pull my finger he ended up
causing 700 dollars in damage whoa that
stuff immediately and the funny thing is
he just looks like a regular office
worker no a joke a name that's what you
need to have weapons when you own a
store like that
Nadine so you need different weapons oh
yeah cuz you can't pull a gun on that
guy right you need different weapons so
in a situation like that he clearly
looks like he's not going to rob the
place that's why you bring out the spike
bet yeah part of the mace real quick
yeah or something you know you got
different weapons to gauge the situation
you're not going to shoot him but she
could take a [ __ ] bat to the face
like that mm depends I wonder if that
guy is [ __ ] like the the violent guy
if he knows how to fight can it look
like it could fit most people are know
how to fight they don't act
yeah they're very controlled I wonder
what will happen if someone jumped the
counter and started fighting and beating
yes but he's so mad he probably wants to
fight even if it's sloppy because I saw
this video the other day these two white
gentlemen they look like they're in
college and there was a smaller guy who
seemed to have a Napoleon complex and
another larger man who was very much
bigger than him now usually in these
videos is usually small guy that whoops
the big dudes ass but the little guy was
young at the big guy and he goes hate me
I dare you I [ __ ] dare you
I'll [ __ ] you up and he goes just calm
down you know hey man you need to relax
stop yelling he goes no you think I'm a
[ __ ] then he just knocks about super
fast
amazing how quick his speed was I didn't
see it happen the guy just you know when
you get hit so hard people go spit this
was it then look like one of those
soccer boppers it's not good news like
this it was crazy and the guy just
walked upstairs me much sleep Wow yeah
those are done I see that could happen
in that situation too I want to own a
liquor store just so something can
happen like that did a magic spell
discrepant doesn't ever have any stories
of like I used to get an argument a lot
with people but he always had guns like
under the register and all that stuff
and he never got robbed or anything but
I do remember like people just coming
into the store like with attitude you
know we're just walk in and stare at
them like hey you got this like no we
don't have that why don't you got that
it's like the [ __ ] because we don't
[ __ ] carry that [ __ ] that's my
parents or dude you you all talk about
bad [ __ ] attitude man Sacramento hot
day a hundred degrees Fahrenheit girl
walks in her hair is not on point she's
in a pissed ass [ __ ] mood or watch
what happens though she comes in why so
expensive
what's that tax with the [ __ ] why y'all
try think that [ __ ] money for multi
[ __ ] you want some free samples thanks
David [ __ ] moving all good or should
you get some free that all happy and
[ __ ] oh yeah so sometimes though women
when your hair is on point you guys got
some bad ad twos men because this is
directly connected to this right here
and have self-image it's like a mood
ring I got a look at the girl's hair
yeah Oh goddamn it though when your hair
is like
looking [ __ ] good tell me your mood
is not fantastic it's more my makeup
than I need to really awesome maybe the
black old angel black oh when the hairs
on point to this [ __ ] mood spike yeah
it's awesome really mad right now but
I'm gonna good hair there so you know
what like okay yeah okay that's what it
is yeah so anyway the police are looking
for the food they described him as a
white male in his 30s about five feet
ten inches tall weighing about 180
pounds there's a clear shot of his face
though they should be able to find his
ass nice whatever yeah so this actually
happened back in February and then the
police released this video to try to get
more eyeballs on it try to ID this guy
I'm surprised what they were talking
about me too because I'm like it can
just be over this bag of Eminem's I'm
almost a hundred percent sure he's just
like lost his job or some [ __ ] or he
just had a terrible [ __ ] - if his car
got decline isn't it in the system so
that's the thing police can't find them
because of the fact that his car was
declined it didn't go so there's no
purchase yeah and it only shows the last
four digits of his card since it didn't
go through so they couldn't find them
that way the bank can't release that
information well do not even know which
yeah right yes they can't find out
because I'd only have four digits I
don't know I don't know like the whole
details I just thought they hit a dead
end with that I always wanted to do this
thing at my parents store was that under
the counter I saw it on training day you
know when the under the bed he just had
that shotgun that swivels around yeah so
I wanted to have the same thing my
shotgun under this counter so you know
if somebody tries to rob us they don't
even have to see me pull up the gun it's
just like that and it's blast right
belittle it and you're [ __ ] dead oh
yeah I always wanted to do that put like
a button yeah what's that gonna do hope
you guys enjoyed that video but if you
didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discuss just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up
[Music]